(audience applauding)
(clock ticking)
Dorothy Gurley made headlines
as being not only a grandmother to five,
but her 50 years of work
that continues today as a nurses aide at the same hospital
in Long Island.
So we wanted to celebrate
her amazing career on the front lines
and the dedication she has to her family.
I mean, how does she do it?
In fact, I want to ask her, Dorothy, welcome.
(audience clapping)
Hi Drew.
Hello.
I'm so excited to talk to you because
I have so many questions.
Okay, I think your work ethic is so admirable, infallible
and just inspirational
and you've dedicated decades of your life to your job
and like, what keeps you motivated
since the day you started?
You're just going so strong.
What is it that is inside of you
that pushes you forward to be this prolific and amazing?
I love working with the patients.
I like coming in and I enjoy my job
and I like what I'm doing.
Yeah.
And I like helping patients that need help.
You talk about
the importance of having a purpose in your life
and have you bestowed this wisdom
onto your children and grandchildren?
I always tell them to, when you get work,
come to work do you work, mind your business,
do you work and go home.
What made you be that kind of person?
Because when I come to work, I do my job.,
I don't get into gossiping and I mind my business.
(audience laughing)
A lot more people could learn that lesson.
Dorothy, am I right?
Yes.
I hear that you have no plans to retire,
how does your family feel about that?
They leave it up to me, whatever I want to do,
and I don't have any plans to retire.
I love what I'm doing, I love coming to work.
And I love at the hospital at work, it's like a family.
I love that so much.
I noticed that you look absolutely radiant and beautiful,
I heard that you said
don't leave the house without makeup on,
is that true 'cause you look gorgeous?
Yes.
I think your family and those around you
are so inspired by you, I'm getting inspired by you,
I was so excited to talk to you.
And speaking of talking to people,
I spoke to your family
and they have a little message for you.
Take a look.
Thank you, mom for everything you have done,
you have been amazing,
you have worked hard all your life
and I admire you and I look up to you.
I love you, enjoy your time.
I just want to say how amazing you are,
how beautiful, how loving
and hard working you are,
and I strive to be like you someday.
Hi grandma, we love you, we miss you
and we appreciate everything you do for us.
This is the time to take a break and relax.
Happy Mother's Day, we love you
and we can't wait to see you.
(audience applauding)
Hi Dorothy,
how does that make you feel may I ask?
Great.
Well, Dorothy, we just want to celebrate you
and your work ethic, and I hear you like to shop?
Yes.
So we're granting you a Grandma's Time out,
and I know we're going to have to make you take it
'cause you won't do it for yourself.
So our friends at Nordstrom
are going to give you a $5,000 gift card.
(audience clapping)
I know, thank you Nordstrom.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And a virtual styling session
with one of their in-house stylists, if you would like
and we just want you to pamper yourself and take this time,
we're going to throw in a lunch and a spa day
and all the things and we heard that you love makeup,
and I really took to heart,
the don't go out of the house without makeup.
So I'm going to put together a huge goodie box,
of all our flower beauty products, makeup, hair, everything.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Dorothy Gurley.
Thank you and thank you for having me on your show.
Thank you for being the person
that's literally the purpose of why we're here.
So right back at you, thank you, Dorothy Gurley,
it's an honor to hang out with you.
(upbeat music)